the recent terrorist attacks in Belgium
France and Denmark and similar
atrocities in the past show the urgent
need to step up against violence
radicalization file and radicalization
extremism is one of the big political
and social issues of today and of course
we do everything we can to defend our
European values against violent radicals
with the full force of law and justice
and security however we can and will do
more to protect our youth from the
dangerous ideas of radicals European
youth and education ministers are
joining forces together today we focus
on the role of teachers youth workers
and other social professionals their
contribution can be extremely valuable
mr. bizz Markie Nick announced that have
appointed a special envoy for the
Prevention of extremism in the
Netherlands she will report on the best
practices on the subject and naturally
also on the practices that doesn't work
well today we discussed how our program
should be conducted in the future we
have two substantive items on the agenda
the adoption of conclusions of Europeana
and a debate on audio-visual policy I'm
very glad that the council adopted these
conclusions they are by giving renewed
political guidance to this important and
unique European project for digital
cultural heritage commissioner etting
are presented his proposal for revising
the audiovisual media surface directive
after that ministers gave their initial
reactions to the proposals ministers
generally welcomed proposals and my
impression is that they did not only
welcome the proposals but that there
were no fundamental differences in the
council today sports ministers adopted
conclusions and good governance in major
sports events the Commission fully
supports these conclusions major sport
events bring many advantages to the
country's hosting them however these
events must
managed properly during all stages
strengthening good governance is one of
my political priorities in this policy
area that's why I'm pleased that we also
had a dynamic debate on the role of
public authorities in better addressing
governance in sport recent scandals have
shown that we must time and again
underline the principles of good
governance we all agreed that
governments must play an active role in
good governance issues working closely
together with sport organizations